Hello guys, no intro, we're going straight in.
Because I was like, if we let the intro play, like, her debut would have been like, oh yeah, her debut is literally starting now.
Like, I was like, we're going straight in.
If I had an intro in, guys, if I had an intro in, we would have missed, like, I don't know, like, already, they would have started their, uh, Lorde video.
I was like, oh man, I should have started a little early so I could just talk a little bit, but it's too late.
I, I, I agree to, I'm just doing my best.
Anyway, there won't be any visuals or audio of the debut stream, so please, uh, check out the link in the pinned messages to watch along with me.
I haven't done a debut watch along in a long time.
I tend to usually, in my opinion.
I tend to usually, uh, if I, I don't, I think I talked about it before, during my last, uh, sponsored watch along.
By the way, this is sponsored, guys.
Um, this is, uh, sponsored by B for Mirai to watch their newest, I guess, I think, Gen 4 debut.
And I'll be watching their first up, uh, first streamer, which her name is Poma, Poma Pon.
Poma Pon?
Or, I think it's Poma Pon, because it's like, she's like a cheerleader.
She's like a hyena.
She's like a girl, VTuber, cheerleader, so I assume it's like Poma Pon.
Um, I think, oh, I think her mascots are like Pomeranians.
I mean, that makes a lot of sense.
Like, that makes sense, you know, like, uh, but I personally, um, I have, I'm sorry, I have coffee right now.
My body is not used to streaming on Sunday, like, for three plus years.
I have, I have usually made Sunday my rest day.
I just chugged down some coffee, like, real quick.
Um, literally, my body was, like, shutting down.
Because I was like, usually I take a nap right now.
Or I sleep in.
Um, but I was like, oh man, okay, body, you gotta work with me.
I'm sponsored today, body.
You gotta fucking work with me today.
Um, so I have coffee in my hand at the moment.
Iced coffee, by the way.
I don't drink warm coffee, I just don't like warm, warm coffee.
Oh my god, we could have had the intro playing.
I thought we were going, oh my god, we could, we actually could have had the intro playing!
It's okay, It's okay.
We had a little introduction for today.
Um, but like I said, I tend to not watch, uh, debut streams because, um, I feel like debut streams are not an accurate representation...
This is the presentation of the VTuber in general.
I think like debut stream usually a lot of VTubers are like incredibly nervous and like Very nervous and everything.
So, um, oh my gosh, what is this?
This is her lore video and I usually watch like her like other peep their streams after like one or two weeks After they debut to see what they're like because usually in the first week They're all like trying to figure out who they are as a person So I tend to like off my free time.
I tend to know I don't watch debut streams in general All right her lore video
Oh my god, okay her outfit with the heart window
Just like oh my god
Yeah, the contrast after people get acclimated yeah
Lore directed and written by Oh Yeah, it's like those like 2000s 2000s like advertisements for videos oh My gosh, this is like an actual class I think like V for Mirai is like whole lore as a company is that they're a school Which is like you become a VTuber to go back to school.
I become a VTuber to like
Escape reality.
I don't want to relive school I don't want to relive.
I don't want to relive school
Take off the- I shouldn't say that Well,
I'm gonna say take off your hair clip there's too many I don't know what you guys think I was going to say.
Look at that tailed goat.
I mean, she is a hyena.
Dogs love to wag their tails.
Isn't she like the only cheerleader?
That's sad.
Being like having a cheer tryouts and then nobody else trying out because you're literally the only cheerleader.
Wait, hyenas are actually cats?
I didn't know that.
I mean, that would make sense.
Actually, that does make a little sense.
That does make sense.
Oh, it says 2022?
Wait, you're right.
Oh my god.
Wait, they're not new?
I thought they were new students.
What is the history?
I mean, oh they're closer to cats than dogs?
Then what kind of species are they?
She said that she hates humans.
Is that warrior cats?
Oh.
Warrior cats were popular around the time um...
Hurry!
It's furries or hags.
It's one or the other.
Visual novel style introduction.
The hardest part.
Okay.
I remember the hardest part regarding Lorde debut streams is also...
It's so hard to have a creative debut stream um that like no one has done before because everything has done.
Everything has been done and you're always like especially if you're like debuting for the first time.
Um there is a budget like obviously like um you gotta fund everything yourself or there is like a small budget.
And obviously especially if you're new to the whole vtubing thing it's like depends on like how much you're willing to invest into it and if you'll have like a return on a return investment in the in your debut thing.
This is very difficult especially if you want a debut stream that catches people's attention.
Also yeah I never thought lore was important as many people forget it after a week.
That is also true.
People, a lot of debut streams, they will have like really complicated lore.
But then like...
They like...
This is why I tend to like see what they're like one to two weeks after the debut stream.
Because it's interesting to see how their personality settles.
And how they like diverge from the lore.
It's always funny because it's like, I am the...
I am...
I am the most powerful, powerful creature in the world and I am here to destroy society.
And then like two years later, they're like, I...
Oh man, I love getting bubble tea and hanging out and hanging out with everybody and...
Oh man, she got rejected again.
I've never been to a school with actual cheerleaders.
I think it's because like I went to international school.
And like...
We just...
I just...
We just didn't have enough people to be cheerleaders.
Like...
I think...
I don't know if it's an American thing.
I don't know if it's like an American thing.
But I've never actually had like an opportunity to like see cheerleaders in the wild.
Like real cheerleaders.
Is it like an American thing?
I know you can like make a lot of money being a cheerleader because of like...
You get to do it like NFL and stuff like that.
That's really impressive though.
Like...
Gen 4...
Like for a new gen to get like 50,000 subscribers before they debut.
That's incredibly impressive.
That's really good for them.
Are cheerleaders real?
I don't know if America just invented it for like TV or movies.
Oh, she's...
She's a yandere.
Is America...
Yes, they are very real.
I...
God, I hope they're real because their American money is so much better than almost the rest of the world except for euros.
And the British pound.
What I love about NFL is that it only exists in America.
I think it's...
I think it's funny because like, you know, it's like all the other sports that America loves to play exists in the rest of the world.
But the NFL is literally just in America.
Yes!
It literally doesn't exist anywhere else.
We played it in Brazil this year.
Yeah, this year.
It only just started.
The World Championships of NFL.
Only in America.
Sorry.
What about the Canadian football?
We have a Canadian football?
That's how I feel about it.
I didn't even realize there's a Canadian football.
So, we got a three-point finish.
Like footballing.
Oh, shit.
We're good.
Oh, my God.
Is that MSN?
Like...
Oh, no.
It's AIM...
She is a hack.
There's no way.
How does she know how AAM looks like?
I thought it was MSN.
I didn't realize there's something before MSN.
I didn't even know what the thing before MSN looks like.
How does she know what the thing looked like before MSN?
That's creative.
That's cute.
That's cute, but also AIM.
Guys, her eyes are up there.
Guys, her eyes are up here, guys.
Guys, remember where her eyes are.
Remember where her eyes are.
Did anyone sign up for a cheer tryouts?
Is this a cheer tryouts?
Are we all like...
Did she like force us?
Did she like force our names to sign up for a cheer tryouts?
Looking respectively.
Oh my god.
I think...
Okay, what I love about her skin suit is that...
Oh wait, no, it's her actual skin.
What I love about her entire being is that...
Oh my god.
Is that...
There's more movement down there than there is at the... at the hair.
Oh my god.
They just know where the... they got the priorities correct.
That's true.
Alright, what are the activities?
For cheer tryouts?
Ma'am, I don't think that's what you do at cheerleading.
Wait, you're right.
Why are there grenades on her...
Wait!
Wait, you're right.
Why are there grenades on her skirt?
Oh, she plays Fallout.
She's like a... I guess like a long RPG... a long game streamer.
Oh shit, that's... just like me.
Oh shit, that's...
just like me.
I'm sorry for talking over here, guys.
I'm sorry!
I'm not used to just... like... like... not talking for a while.
For watch-a-longs.
Wait, are hyenas stupid?
Are hyenas stupid?
Hyenas are part of intelligent and loving hy...
Wait, what's wrong with her?
I literally... I literally...
These animals are fierce, social, and incredibly smart.
Wait a minute.
What's wrong?
What happened?
That's what she said!
She's like, I'm a hyena, so I'm stupid.
I'm like, is that true?
I thought...
She's just special.
Is it because she's...
Well, crows are smart.
Yeah, but I... everybody knows I'm stupid.
It doesn't matter what type of animal or what type of... or what type of thing I am.
Like, I'm...
Oh, wait, she has a heart on...
Sorry, my eyes were respectfully at her eyes, by the way.
But I just noticed a heart.
Guys, it took me this long because respectfully, I was not looking at that place.
I'm smart.
It's like a
heart within a heart.
Alright.
How else are you gonna have explosions at your child's?
Alright, so there's no liability forms that were signed.
There's no...
Alright,
people definitely did not sign any liability... liability contracts.
Like a true American.
Wouldn't it be funny if she's not even American in the end?
Like...
And she's not even American in the end.
Oh my God, do a flip!
Do a flip!
Oh my God, she's flipping!
Oh my God!
Wait, is she like actually moving while this happens?
Oh my...
Oh!
Toki, can you do a flip?
She's too...
She's always been too deep.
She actually did a flip!
Oh my God!
Oh my God.
What is she?
What the fuck?
What?
Biblically accurate hyena!
She's a biblically accurate hyena!
Wait, is she doing a fucking split?
What is that?
Guys, I wrote this debut, by the way.
I wrote this debut.
I was the ghost writer.
Do not be afraid.
Yes!
I mean, to be fair, I noticed that...
I'm pretty sure all the B4MRI girls get their 3D eventually.
Like, really fast, actually, too.
No...
Oh my God...
Not the AI for like that.
The reason why it's really cursed is that you're not supposed to use illustrations for it.
I've seen...
I've seen people use that program.
It's actually so fucking weird.
You can actually...
Like, if you can use...
It's supposed to be, like, with regular pictures of people.
And it's so...
It's so accurate.
I saw, like...
One of my...
One of the TikToks...
Not TikToks...
One of the YouTube shorts people I watch...
That does, like, Peach and Bowser cosplays...
He, like...
She made, like, the Bowser cosplayer do a Fortnite dance with just a picture.
High energy?
Well...
Well, when you...
Especially if you're new...
And you have a lot of eyes on you...
On your first debut, you usually have, like, a lot of energy.
And that's just based off my experience.
Because when I debuted...
I had so much fucking energy.
Because I was so nervous, too.
So I had to, like...
Expel all my energy here.
Do we win anything?
Oh, the nerves is...
In game, right?
Wait, she didn't say in game, guys.
Guys, she didn't say in game.
It's her first impression.
Yeah.
Especially when...
There's so many, uh, debuts nowadays.
Um...
You know, you have to have, like...
A lot of energy going in.
Because it's your first impression.
Oh, yeah, no.
A lot of...
A lot of people drink coffee before their debut.
Because they're, like...
Um...
I know, like, people would be, like, so scared or nervous that they can't sleep the day before their debut.
So they would, like, drink, like, caffeine the day...
Like...
Before streaming.
I mean...
True.
I don't really watch a lot of anime.
But, like, I know that.
About the second season.
They, like, what?
They, like, changed a lot of stuff about Promised Neverland, right?
For the second season.
They diverted from the manga for some reason.
Also, thank you guys for the Super Chess.
I'm sorry I can't read, uh, read them off the bat.
For today's stream.
Alright, now they'll never send hearts again.
Noooo!
My heart is broken!
I'll never send a heart again!
You never even superchatted, surefory!
Don't be a fucking liar!
What was the last anime I watched?
Oh my god that's hard to say.
I don't even...
I think JJK... JJK the episode before the city.
Pink team!
I'm pink team!
Oh, is this chat interaction?
I always wanted to do a chat interaction...
A chat interaction game.
They always seem really fun.
They're like, you know, like Twitch plays Pokemon.
I need to hire a programmer for that shit.
Because I know a lot of like chat interaction stuff usually works on Twitch but not on YouTube.
So it's like a whole new thing.
Guys, I'm on pink team, guys.
Are you really gonna let me lose?
Guys!
This is a crime!
This is a fucking crime!
Yeah.
Stop rigging it.
That's right.
We're gonna rig...
We're gonna rig the debut.
I swear to God.
As pink team, we deserve to...
Why would you love yourself?
Why would you say that?
Wait, we're...
How do we know who wins?
How do we...
Guys.
What's the point of like rigging the debut when it doesn't go my way?
It's...
Robbed!
We were robbed!
I spite voted for blue.
That's fucked.
That's so fucked.
What?
Oh.
Mama!
Is this a pager?
Is...
What year is this?
How much are pagers now?
How much is a pa...
Do people still use that?
Do doctors actually use it?
Pagers are $300?
Oh, no.
It's 20 to 80.
For a basic numeric pager.
What year is this?
I don't know what year is this anymore.
First it's 2022 and then she pulled up AIM.
And then she's debuting now.
And now there's a pager?
Now...
Hospitals use pagers.
Does she look like she's in the hospital?
Oh my god.
We're back.
Now we're in 2010.
Party rocking's in the house tonight.
Ba da da da da da ba da da da da da.
Da da da da...
I like...
I like that you can see the...
The...
The big ol' dot AI.
Hey guys, that's where she got it.
The score on that line is weird.
Are they like in hyperbolic time chamber?
Like, you know how they...
In some shows they're like they're trapped in the 80s forever.
Like...
Is she a time travel teacher leader?
Rockin' in the house tonight.
Everybody's gonna have a good time.
I'm getting whiplash.
It's a sing-along!
Shake it.
Rockin' in the house tonight.
Everybody's gonna have a good time.
Guys, I lived at a time when party... every fucking school assembly, there will be the dance club doing god damn party rocking.
And it fucking never stops.
Like, it'll be like a school assembly and we're like, guys, we're gonna do a demonstration!
And then it's always party rocking.
It's never anything else.
It's Gangnam Style or it's party rocking.
I fucking hated it.
Anyway, I love this song.
I just... I just hated the dance.
Rockin'
in the house tonight.
There's also I got a... Oh, and then...
What was it?
I saw on Twitter, someone was like, what does the fox say?
It was that generation's skibbity toilet.
But that is a fucking insult to what does a fox say.
How dare...
I felt like... I felt like that was actually a crime for saying that.
That is a lie.
I was like, how dare you...
How dare they... What slander is this?
That is actually a hate crime.
Like...
Get up, get down.
Put your hands up to the down.
You know what's sad about that?
You know what's sad about the... the...
I'm sad because they broke up after having like... like 500,000 hit songs together.
Because they were like uncle and nephew.
Duel.
And then they broke up after... after like all their songs got... were hits.
And then... and then... because it was money.
It was money.
They're like... they were just really greedy.
So they broke up and tried to pursue solo careers and obviously it didn't work.
Which sucks because their songs are actual bangers.
Like... they're like really good like dance music.
Yeah, apparently the uncle was...
Like a douchebag.
Yeah, they were really, really good.
Really, really good dance music.
When you get DMCA'd, this background track is not the actual...
This background track is definitely not Party Rockin'.
So she's safe.
As somebody that has listened to Party Rockin'...
So much in my youth.
I know for sure this background track is not gonna get DMCA'd.
Like...
I've heard it so many times.
Party rocking in the house tonight.
Ba dum ba dum bum ba dum bum bum.
Ba dum ba dum ba dum bum ba dum.
Ba da da da da.
Shake it.
Ha ha ha ha ha Every day I'm shuffling.
Ba dum ba dum bum bum ba dum.
Ba da da dum bum bum ba dum ba dum.
Ba da dum bum ba dum ba dum.
Ba da ba dum bum ba dum ba dum.
Ha ha ha ha.
Can I have my lawyer look at this contract?
All right.
I need like one to two business days.
And have my lawyer look at this contract.
Guys, never sign a contract.
Guys, never sign a contract right away, guys!
Guys!
Dragoons!
Guys, get your lawyers to read the fine print!
As somebody that's paid a lot of money and have two lawyers on retainer.
Do not do that!
It's okay.
You can like...
You can get like regurgitated...
Uh...
Lawyer advice!
Do not use me for lawyer advice, by the way.
Do not... What is that word for?
For like... Oh, do not use me for trickle-down lawyer advice, guys.
I pay too much money to spread that lawyer advice to you guys.
BabyTuber told me to do it.
Politely say no.
Yay!
It's not rigged!
Say no.
Say...
She's crying!
Why are you laughing?
Say no.
Insist no.
She literally said she has a restraining order!
Why would I sign the contract after that?
That doesn't make it better!
Those are like red flags!
Red flags!
Women crying by one weakness!
Oh my gosh, she's about to go Monica on us.
Oh, it is Monica!
We're in space!
You see that?
We're in space chat!
Gives the best totally official legal advice.
Yes.
Thank you!
Oh my god, we got the Doki Doki Literature Club ending!
It's the secret easter egg ending!
Like how Silent Hill has the little doggy!
Like, you know when you get the secret easter egg ending and it's always that dog and the UFO?
This is it!
Oh, she has a lot of different expressions.
No.
Yay!
Wait, what?
Closing the tab.
I'm joking!
Old F4!
Guys, remember the hot crazy scale?
We have to sign the contract on the hot crazy scale.
It's like from good ol' Barney Simpson, who is the most reliable guy out there.
Wait, wait!
What is this?
What is this contract?
Alterations to terms.
Reserves the right to alter these terms.
The contract is internal and cannot...
Guys, the contract is eternal!
The contract...
She has three.
Look, biblically accurate.
Hyena.
What do you mean, why did I sign it?
Why didn't you sign it?
And then you said eternal.
Palm squad training video.
Stop being dramatic!
Dragoons!
I said calmly.
Alright, what's the palm squad...
Wait, is that a DVD?
Why is the DVD of VHS quality?
Why?
Oh my god!
Look, there's puppets!
I love how the DVD is like VHS quality.
What year is this?
This is a hyperbolic time chamber.
It's a CDR.
Why is it...
It's a hot new technology.
Don't keep...
That's really cool.
The puppet.
It's like a full on muppet.
It's a VHS rip-off on CDR.
Wait, how do you know about that?
What does that even mean?
Oh my god.
The RTX on is like so HD.
Oh my god!
She even made the dog?
Oh, that's cute!
Cute!
Oh, that's why she wanted to do crafting streams.
She can like make puppets.
I like copyright free Mario on the top right.
Did you guys see that?
She's perfect Doki.
I love her.
This would be the only Super Chat I've read because how fucking dare you.
On my stream.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Am I getting NTR'd right now?
On my sponsored stream.
And guys, none of you guys signed, right?
Okay, I'm joking.
I'm joking, guys.
Wait, is this a call?
Oh my god.
I would never kill you guys like how she killed that sock puppet.
Intentionally.
If it's an accident, that's not my fault.
You've done it so many times.
It was all an accident.
I would never do it intentionally.
They were all an accident.
Pom Squad.
It's okay.
Our names aren't on it.
That's not a legal binding name.
I don't think she even has Pom Squad trademarked.
So like...
Legally...
It's not legally binding, guys.
Call your lawyers!
Quick Trademark it!
Quick Trademark Pom Squad!
Call your lawyers!
Holy shit!
Cheerleading is so hardcore!
Any cheerleaders in chat, do you back me up on this?
Is this true?
Is this what cheerleading is like?
Damn.
I didn't even realize Cheerleading is this hardcore.
Where is she?
That was really creative.
The puppet thing.
And it really showed her creativity on what you can see on the crafting stuff too.
Since I believe her main branding has to be her crafting.
What?
MySpace?
Are we in the 80s, 90s, 2000s, 2010s?
What year?
What year are we in?
Oh, oh, it's over.
Oh, okay.
Oh, that was the ending screen.
2024.
Are we in 2024?
I can't tell anymore.
I can't.
That was a fever dream.
Oh my god.
I really like her creativity in terms of like how she presented the whole 90s.
I guess it's the 90s aesthetic.
The whole 90s to 2010s aesthetic.
It was really interesting to see.
I actually, I never knew what AIM looked like.
So I was like, what the fuck is that?
That does not look like MSN.
So I was like, oh my god, AIM.
The thing before MSN?
I think that was like literally the first time I've ever seen it.
But yeah, her little puppets were, her little puppets were really cute.
I really enjoyed the puppet section because it really does show like, like what her creativity.
And it sort of gives me the glimpse of like what her, what her stream could turn into and what her branding could be in the next couple of weeks.
So that part is like what's...
is the most interesting.
Because every debut stream it was like, it's like, what is it that makes this VTuber special?
And the puppet thing is like her niche that I can see that she can develop a lot more later on too.
Yeah, it's a good preview.
And yeah, she has some, she has like Lollipop Chainsaw Repop, which is like a good game choice for her.
Because like her aesthetic is practically that game.
And then she has her Handcam stream, which is like...
which is basically, I guess, making puppets and then talking about her favorite game.
And I assume Half-Life is her...
Half-Life is her favorite game series.
Because she talked about it earlier.
All right, guys, I got to send you off to the next debut.
But I hope you guys enjoyed this Watch-A-Lot.
I usually don't really know what to do when I'm doing debut Watch-A-Lot.
So I hope I did an okay job.
I hope I did!
I hope I did an okay job watching a lot.
Because it's hard to balance like...
For me, I'm like wondering, oh, when do I talk?
When do I commentate?
But yeah, I'm going to go right into the next debut stream now.
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
Feel free to check out Pullman Pollen.
Her debut was very interesting to watch.
Very creative in terms of what she is going into in her future as a VTuber.
But yes, I'm going to send you off.
To the next debut now.
As always everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check up.
And move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!